hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
with me Oh Oh you new new to introduce
yourself thank you Alvarado I've been
here long enough you know the drill hate
it when people just wait idly by or ISM
as if I'm the host who's supposed to
introduce people but BS is that right
we're gonna watch a video from nukes top
fives today five scary ghost videos to
give you nightmares don't watch alone
that's why I have Kat here with me
cats podcast villains of history has
been taken off skyrocketing number one
on iTunes charts everywhere hundred
thousand downloads a month can you
believe that don't look into these
numbers but what you can do is check out
the episode I was just on who do we talk
about cat we talked about the
Gainesville Ripper who inspired the
movie scream and the guy who inspired
the am evil horror series and then
speaking of which scream you just had
Jamie Kennedy on line two didn't you I
did we talked about Dave Koresh that
cult leader
from the 90s nice these are all things
that lead to no yellow dollar bill signs
on youtubes a great podcast they always
discuss two major iconic villains of
history of real-life people you guys
should go check it out seriously it's
actually really funny and it's always
entertaining to listen to 200,000
downloads a month if I'm not mistaken
[Music]
cop I'm ghost caught on camera okay yeah
we'll see a playful spirit
reddit user bleach Fung says that he and
his brothers have experienced a very
bizarre haunting throughout their entire
childhood in their family home it would
often hear the sound of someone loudly
digging through their large collection
of Legos even though there was no one
else in the house late one night we hear
the familiar sound of shuffling Legos
and run down the hall to record they
caught something incredibly creepy on
camera
[Music]
there's literally nothing in here this
is yeah there's no beer
oh boy oh that's so scary
the toy was battery-powered and that was
why the head moved bleach posted the
toys neck to show that there was no
mechanical mechanism at work
so it's bleach pong in this family oh
that is nipple chill worthy indeed by
the way you can check out bleach yeah my
nipples are chilling story I can't
comment on that in today's day and age
[Laughter]
Philippine a nun half Filipino alright
security camera
and they saw this live chilling CCTV
footage there speaking my language
that looks CG itis
eyes yeah
you cured it whoa
that is weird like that's a ghost for
sure that's the devil when I go through
a lot Baron gate security guards I mean
that's a very is Franco TV sees crazy
crossroads and urban ghosts urban
exploration is also my trustworthy guy
those TV decides that they should try a
seance and then things get a little
spooky
okay is what is is k2 I guess that's a
good ghost meter I guess something the
question you asked I don't believe this
you could just have your assistant in
the background throwing sure someone
could just be slamming the door yeah no
I want CCTV on the whole house so I can
know that there's nobody slamming stuff
even then I wouldn't believe it
woah hey I mean it's a good job on the
video that's cuz you eat some bad shrimp
because you have a minute the
chiropractor had that before like I want
to see before -
looks down with someone hit you in the
bruised okay okay let's see oh that is
effective again they could have a
production assistant or the fake alien
head and just stick it in and then stick
it out one something I made to be period
that well it looks like a doll or an
alien toy when they go inside to check
there's no one there I mean I'd still
say that kudos on how they put this
together yes but I also don't think it's
real thank you Miss bust all of these
things yeah those busts I think you're
so good at doing it that you don't even
know what it's called I need to name it
see see see
[Music]
[Music]
but this story takes another very odd
twist oh really
because a few days later Joe from urban
ghost ever been explorations decides to
return to the house by himself
and he accidentally catches more creepy
footage as he speaks to the camera I
wouldn't go back without that very
there's people outside right
what oh this place is freakin haunted oh
my god
he had his assistant like hopelessness
and I was I was burned on my back you
know it's so kind just wanna come back
here just whatever
some bizarre shadow figure that a young
girl keeps peeking I know that young
girl has a pumpkin I think you know it
her to be a young girl so did these
girls tellers catch real paranormal
evidence that one if you speak your eyes
it looks like it all like it guys like
alien race yeah we caught the devil of
Saudi Arabia and streams them live quote
the house of the devil
you might expect it doesn't go well okay
you should make a hunting video like our
own fake hunting video now be real
how he's praying slaw
that's not gonna work we all know that
the real God is Cthulhu Oh what was that
waiting
okay I want to see his camera right on
the door as it shuts so I know there's
no one shutting it is very committed
acting
whoo whoa
his emotional performance I believe that
that's Ruthie - does that just open by
itself something there don't go up the
stairs soon the girls gonna push you
down hey I wanna watch that [ __ ] it's a
live stream he said
oh I would not go upstairs I do not go
upstairs have you tried getting out of
there
turkey baster is this like the place
where they mm-hmm that was a good one
that was a good my question exactly do
I'm gonna cry this number three second
last the second-to-last okay yes this
was good Suellen Bari decides to finally
just get out of there
yeah you can watch more of a doulas
adventures over on this youtube channel
or check ghost in the cabin okay
paranormal investigator ricky
Velasquez's live-streaming his
exploration lives here captained by up
stern in the middle of nowhere as he
approaches the building he sees
something absolutely terrified
my guess is to leave
[Music]
try not to try not to feel what what who
I even attempt he sees that he runs
toward it
I couldn't tell what it was that he saw
my Vega personally Ricky charges toward
the building structure that he finds no
sign of the strange woman woman how do
you know it's a woman I see a ghost
let's not do that right now
yeah why did he just a super gender
their gender keep keep politics out of
my ghost reaction because kid I couldn't
tell if it was a man or a woman or
anything honestly that was like okay I
say hidden agenda with you always and
forever from what I know with Kat
Alvarado is that whenever he told a
ghost story all she tries to do is tell
you how your traumatic experience was
much of BS now can you explain to me
this Bionicle one no when the head moved
that was crazy that was creepy I was
first out bite person was the freakiest
one to me that I like the number five
pick and I got to say like in my
experience when I've been down in
Nicaragua I have experienced like
seemingly haunted toys that go off in
the middle of the night and it is so
scary when it happened so to me like
this was the most realistic that's sad
say you've got like a five-year-old
cousin who's like very tiny and or a
little person in your family who you
could borrow to make a hoax video right
checkout person today hey if I had a
cousin who was a little person we would
be up to so much mischief like we
absolutely where's all these boxes
they're gonna usually be someone who's
hiding back there who's like crouched
and just moves oh come on really
oh gosh yeah you can't see it standing
up there's all that stuff blocking the
view are you talking about close about
it but look there's a stack of toys over
there not very clearly press up against
the wall the toys one day the devil is
gonna pay you a visit cattle prove it
now here's I can prove you're just some
visual effects right is that white
behind the boxes or in front of the
boxes
in front of the boxes vision computers
it's in front of them don't see it is in
front oh it is in front that is freaking
yep there we go cats a believer now you
can attend church every Sunday well I
believe these ones more when they don't
notice it when they like playback the
footage and they're like wait a minute
what the hell did you see that those are
the ones that get me a little bit more
this one of the Philippines with this
like or like they got some type of
paranormal entity through x-ray vision
on camera wait looks reminds me of this
game I used to play it was on Steam it
was like a zombie killing game
and so it's like shitty graphic effects
can I say shitty uh I prefer you not to
but it's already sad so let's have it
and let's have a go okay it looks like
bad graphics like from like the late
like shitty graphics it's not good I
think that's part of what makes it
effective one thing about all these
videos that I always give them credit
for is that even if I don't ultimately
believe them I always credit them on how
they're assembled because in the moment
they're always creepy in the moment
they're always like ooh something like
this is also different normally it's
like what we've seen with the other ones
there's like a head pop in there or that
thing slightly moved this is pretty this
is pretty extreme yeah it takes a lot of
effort Souter that is fake do you read
the subtitles I think well the one we're
stopped on Rihanna it's a ghost that guy
is dead already guys it's a ghost that
guy is dead already
yes I'm pretty sure he's dead already
guts look at the way he walks guys
that's a ghost for sure imagine why she
doesn't get again finished look that
guy's dead already
it's not the first thing he'd imagined
some Wednesday someone they knew yeah
yeah exactly like wait a minute do we
know that guy thought he died that's
Phillip he was trapped in a well yeah if
it was like I thought he died that's for
maybe it sometime maybe that's not how
they actually said it the reason I don't
believe this third one a it's too
elaborate and then
I just don't quite buy especially when
they're their content is dedicated to
finding these things
yes exactly when it's not about that it
just looks like a happenstance is
something happened and they put it up
then I'm like ooh they're monetizing
finding stuff so they have to find stuff
yeah it just seems a little too
I mean kudos to them for like I said
like they did the Assembly of the video
is really well done there are things
that you were saying and I was like
totally on board with you like what the
whole back thing well that could have
just been a delayed pain reaction that's
finally kicking in or something could
have like had a scratch from like some
other thing that happened they're like
oh yeah we'll say or even more so like
this is Hollywood you could do literally
anything that could have been like
alright I'm gonna hit you with the crew
yeah then we'll film it you see like
when the guy went back to the house and
then there was a little girl shape thing
appearing in the back I probably would
have bought it if he didn't look over oh
yeah cause how is he gonna know that
there's something that's gonna be over
that shoulder let me tell you it rocks
still creepy creepy I still get some
nipple chills that man still serving I
will not ask you you can always
volunteer for mation
yeah you said that didn't like oh no
where I get chills the second the
penultimate one and the final one mean
ultimate oh you're losing big words I
just learned that word today oh yes
quite peculiar that my vocabulary has
expanded upon Oh pulchritudinous means
I'm hot apparently not must it applies
to the dialogues we were having
potentially all right so with Abdullah
Al I'm Bari
I like these last two because they said
that they're live streaming is you can
still fake stuff if your lives yep
absolutely
but this guy I don't care what your
profession if you're hunting when that
kind of craziness is going down
you're by yourself what I found funny
was the irony of how he is praying to
God it's I couldn't tell if you were
like trying to exorcise the demon or if
he was terrified and was praying to God
and like as a shield for himself right
because at that point when you're there
for that long you're praying at it in
you're terrified or listen like teen you
should have bailed like a while ago yeah
he like really does like trust that as
long as he's saying those words he's
gonna be safe side note I just want to
say on the record that I do not believe
in Cthulhu because I don't want to go to
how for for saying that out loud because
it was a jokes just so that like the man
upstairs no it's just want to put that
out there alright anyways
God does not watch my videos everything
all the time but whatever here's the
back to Louann a mythological creature
created by HP Lovecraft you know I have
no idea but I feel like I heard about
him on sell octopus yeah continue how
could it be faked
and my first thought was he could have a
person who's behind the door like
slamming it but he's going through that
door like and it's live stream great
quick like you'd have to rehearse that
many times and having like really
choreographed in order to pull it off
such that the camera would never catch
the people because he's rushing into the
door and then like turning around and
filming that that would be very
impressive to pull off as a faith I give
this one an 80% chance of being legit
yeah for me I'll say that even if
there's possible ways to conclude that
this is not real that the second one
last one the Pendleton one is a hoax I
would still vote that it's real just for
the level of awesome commitment and
assembly that he put together cuz it's a
fake this one a he's acting like he's
really Jeff I'd be well executed and
very well choreographed in rehearse if
it's fake and see even if it's not
people he would have to like invent some
kind of contraption that's being
controlled remotely and opening and
closing the doors and I don't see any
kind of devices we're judging these
ghost videos guys continue to submit
your ghost videos to us so you can win
$10,000 and be the lucky winner for the
best ghost video but yes
and the last one all we learned from
that was this guy is clearly sexist
because he assumed it's a woman am i
right am i right
yeah gosh such man thinking whoa no two
thumbs
get out of my youtube video I say but
either way like how did this one end up
his number I think just for the credit
of a guy spotted something because
number one for bravery although it kind
of does look like when he goes in and
tweets the camera up there's nowhere for
the person to stand this is like an
empty ish structure with no door how
would the person be in the window and
this one's also a livestream I think
that's why that'd be number one because
it's a livestream it's hard to fake
something like that whoo I'm screwed if
Italy recharges it right what do you
spot something that's dark and I guess
if a key you'd have to have had
something unlike a large stick you need
someone there too and then they run away
with the large stick as he's running in
very quickly they like a run back and
exit it so Burton
that would be how you would fake that
which is kind of ridiculous so maybe I
love how seriously you pull that off
I really think we should make our own
like fake haunting and make people guess
how he faked it you really don't have to
watch something if they know it's like
what the friller do it is that it's fake
watch that is it for the challenge of
figuring out how we did it and if they
guess they would know Toby premiere
effects or something without just
friends we find some little people
willing to go you put this bad boy
together and now yes and you along the
way alright alright guys well you can
subscribe to nukes top 5 if you haven't
done so already happy Halloween
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification I'll get notified never got
a youtube video up Ken Alvarado you can
follow her online and make sure to check
out buildings of history the link in the
description
that's a the description area box link
in the description box
for the episode that I just did with Kat
seriously it's a good time did you like
it it was a lot of fun I was editing
that and to know what we were making
lots of jokes how long that means it's
funny